foreign
we're going to talk about since one of
the themes of this conference is
theories of everything in different
fields we'll talk about that with Eric
starting with his geometric Unity theory
in which he attempts to answer some
problems so let's start there because
I'm not actually sure what the problem
is to be solved so Eric let's start with
uh throwing it to you and just asking
you know most when people propose a
grand unifying Theory it's to solve some
problem that's that's hanging out there
that no one has been able to solve
what's the problem that you're
addressing here well first of all
um great to be with you from Bluster
University of Chicago where it's a
little cold it's it's an interesting
point when you say Grand unified that's
actually a technical term
um for combining all the
non-gravitational forces where oddly we
call the unified theory uh the hope for
all four forces that we know about in
the new forces that we don't I think
that really the issue is that you're
trying to
um see whether there are any natural
structures that can explain the
relatively Baroque details of the world
that we see we see
leptons and and quarks we see you know
different forces there are eight gluons
three intermediate Vector bosons a
photon Partridge and a pear tree how do
all of these things in some sense come
from any kind of simple structure so you
know in a certain sense if you think
about a fertilized egg it doesn't appear
that there's much going on in a
fertilized egg before its first cell
division and somehow that blossoms into
thirty thousand cells working in harmony
to create Michael Shermer so that's a
bizarre idea is there any simple
structure which when unpacked unpacks to
the universe that we actually see
and in essence
um The Hope is that it's actually easier
at some point to guess a unified theory
than it is to
um
you know try to do things as we have
piecemeal the piecemeal program appears
to have stalled out around
1973-74 when the standard model fell
into place and of course gravitational
Theory more or less was in place by you
know the late teens early 20s so we have
two relatively stagnant
um pictures that are themselves not
unified
um and in fact imagine that they have to
be unified and then their unification
problems at least within the standard
model of the you know part of the
problem with general relativity is is
that it appears so perfect
um that we don't seem to be able to get
in underneath it's very hard to begin a
sentence without assuming Einstein and
so one question that we have is if
something is going to go beyond Einstein
how do you recover Einstein from a more
fundamental Theory when what he did uh
appears to be Bedrock right so the
problem is is you have Einstein's
general theory of relativity that
describes the large-scale structure of
the universe then you have quantum
physics at the other end and what you're
working on or the problem many people
are working on including yourself is how
to bring those together I don't know
unite them or find something that's
underneath both of them that ties them
together is I'm not even sure that's the
right way to say it I use the word
harmonize to be somewhat agnostic you
see around the late 70s early 80s the
quantum field Theory types
um made a very bold assertion that we
should replace unified field Theory
searches which was sort of Einstein's
view which was hearkening to his uh
you know it was appealing to his sense
of the geometry as a unifying force and
they instead substituted the idea that
we must quantize gravity
and that effectively to submit the uh
the descendants of Einstein to those at
board
and I personally think that was a giant
mistake because we didn't have enough
information I mean we should be agnostic
maybe there are ways of harmonizing them
that don't involve quantizing the
gravitational force
um and keeping it uh in a in a different
state
um that's that's challenging because if
you imagine a macroscopic
um sort of quantum superposition where
you don't know let's say that you had a
Quantum planet right it could be over
here it could be over there as soon as
you do an observation you would imagine
the space-time would either have to be
warped on the left and flat on the right
or warped on the right and flat on the
left and whatever that is uh that was
taken as evidence that gravity must be
submitted to think of this in MMA terms
uh and yet gravity has not wanted to
submit so the hope with string theory
was is that there was only one way to
make gravity submitted that those
theories had to effectively be right but
all this presupposed that
the sleight of hand replacing unified
field Theory which was somewhat agnostic
uh and maybe a little bit bent towards
the relativists that we could substitute
that with the desire to quantize gravity
and I think that that hasn't been
particularly successful now for almost
40 Years of intensive activity the best
minds of a couple of generations
yeah right well let me stand in for the
average person or per person watching
this going what what the hell is this
guy doing what the hell is going on
gravity is one of the four forces okay
when we think of a force we think of
like like a magnet and the little
filings going toward it like it's being
pulled there so the Earth is being
pulled around the the sun that's somehow
exuding some gravitational force and you
know and Newton famously said I'm not
going to even hypothesize about what
this actually is it just follows these
equations and then Einstein said no no
it's not a force like a electromagnetism
it's like a warped space time and the
planet is falling around the Warped
space time of the sun something like
that I'm sure I'm not getting that quite
right but and and so what you're after
here and other people is that maybe
there's something even but beneath that
or unifying that that can then be tied
to this Quantum effect is it is that a
right way to say it well unfortunately
or fortunately it turns out that
electromagnetism is actually a warping
force of its own and that was only oddly
by
um a guy named Robert Herman and uh
another guy named Jim Simons and one
named CN Yang so the world's greatest
hedge fund manager uh and his uh
colleague cian Yang at Stony Brook in
New York figured out that
electromagnetism was uh another example
in fact all the forces are geometric and
have to do with warping and curvature
tensors uh so the odd thing that we've
learned is that um
it's two different geometries and the
reason for titling the the the theory
um geometric Unity is because these two
different kinds of geometries geometries
that is that of Riemann which Einstein
favored for gravity
and the more obscure theory of fiber
bundle curvature which was pioneered by
Charles eresman uh announcation these
two geometries are very similar but not
quite the same and so what we now have
is four forces that are all wrapped up
in uh in geometric warping
so
um it's just not the same kind of
warping it's very very similar so
tantalizingly close
Revenge
right well I frequently say that
um when these when these folks tried to
quantize uh gravity and therefore
quantize geometry
um they they became unsuccessful in the
most romantic way possible because what
they ended up doing was geometrizing the
quantum the quantum is now more
geometric by many of our estimation than
general relativity ever was or can be
like it looks like a child's geometry
whereas the quantum geometry is
unbelievably spectacular
interesting yeah I think part of the
problem some of us have is you know when
you look outside you see physical
objects and you don't see warping or
whatever and if you can extend that with
microscopes and telescopes and so on
um but at some point when you guys dive
deep into these mathematical equations
describing the geometric warping of
space-timers I really have it's hard for
me to glom onto anything metaphorically
in the physical world that would help me
understand that so I mean
we kind of know what geometry is but
when you're talking about like a
mathematical universe or the geometric
shape of the universe or whatever what
what exactly are you talking about well
I highly recommend people uh look up the
YouTube
[Music]
um videos for hop vibration or Planet
hop
or Penrose stairs or Escher staircase in
fact what you're saying is uh is oddly
untrue So when you say when we look
around and we see the world around us
made up of stuff what you're actually
doing is that you are perceiving uh
waves and curvature which have to do
with photons
um so effectively your your eyeballs are
being bombarded with curvature
information sent and Scattered off of
waves I mean what Michael Shermer is is
a collection of waves
um and that you effectively are exciting
uh something called a vector bubble the
medium in which you live when you move
from room to room
um just the way if I
um let's say
move a hose kind of violently if I take
the cord here and I go like that
the particles that make up this medium
don't move in the direction of the wave
you're hoping that when you move rooms
you're going to excite that Medium
called a vector bundle in the Next Room
but the vector bundle is pretty much
staying put it's a hell of a leap of
faith and kind of a weird way to realize
that the going getting a cup of coffee
is a dangerous activity
you're just propagating a wave in a
medium called Michael's room
yes okay so if I get this right so I'm
not actually seeing this pin I'm seeing
photons of light bouncing off of it
going through uh my uh cornea and lens
and hitting the back of my retina where
the energy is transduced into
neurochemical transmitter processes back
to the visual cortex of my brain so the
whole thing is in your retina
yeah so these are all waves and and
that's a kind of a geometric uh process
okay so to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas